CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman
prosecuted sex crimes and also defended
suspects accused of sexual harassment
and assault good morning good morning
all right the next big question could he
face a criminal investigation well we
have to look at where we are many of
these allegations are sexual harassment
that is a request to do something not an
actual action those are not criminal we
also have to remember if a prosecutor or
a woman is going to get involved in a
criminal case that Harvey Weinstein is
presumed innocent and we can't forget
that when we have this discussion we
haven't heard of a prosecutor yet who is
saying I'm going to go forward with a
criminal case could one do that yes but
there are hurdles here number one is it
within the statute of limitations
meaning the time limit you just heard a
story that happens ten years ago not
within the statute of limitations it
would have to be much more recent by the
way a lot of states since the Bill Cosby
episodes have gotten away done away with
statutes of limitations but not for
crimes that be occurred before so then
you have yet another hurdle does the
woman want to go forward many of these
women would not want to go forward with
a criminal case and so how does the
prosecutor if a woman signed a
confidentiality agreement get her in at
all he must use or she must use the
subpoena power of a grand jury if
there's a confidentiality agreement that
woman cannot talk you say a subpoena
would override a confidentiality
agreement yes it's the only way and we
know that from the Bill Cosby case a
woman cannot tell her friends cannot
tell the newspaper cannot tell
television cannot tell the police once
she has signed we also don't know if any
or many of these women have gone to the
police before they may have signed any
confidentiality agreement that's like
Andrea constant with Cosby that's a
different story
do we know whether the Board of
Directors had any oversight in terms of
funds paid to settle well isn't that the
big question
the company would certainly have to face
some civil liability if in fact they
knew something and we have to know when
they knew it if the company knew nothing
if Harvey Weinstein made this out of his
own pocket then we have a different
story but if I'm the company I'm looking
for a complete review and we do know the
company has hired an independent
investigative team to quote learn the
full truth eager to find those findings
out Rikki Kleman thanks for your time